bienvenue dans l'entretien de france 24
l'histoire de mon invitée d'aujourd'hui
raconte l'une des pages les plus sombres
de l'histoire de france celle de la
collaboration et de l'antisémitisme du
régime de vichy qui en juillet 1942
commis selon les mots de jacques chirac
l'irréparable la rafle du vel d'hiv
bonjour lisait de chasse clovis bonjour
merci d'être sur ce plateau aujourd'hui
le 16 juillet 1942 le jour de la rafle
du vel d'hiv il y à 80 ans vous aviez
sept ans vous habitiez avec vos parents
juifs immigrés d'allemagne et d'autriche
et votre demi soeur margot au 50 rue
doudeauville c'est dans le xviiie
arrondissement à paris et des policiers
français sont venus vous cherchez est-ce
que vous pouvez nous raconter ce qui
s'est passé ce jour là
d'abord il faut que je dise que ma
mémoire a beaucoup failli depuis donc il
ya des souvenirs qui sont rapportés
d'autres que j'ai conservés peut
en tout cas ce qui s'est passé ce jour
là c'est que ma mère ma soeur et moi
avons été arrêtés mon père ne l'a pas
été par ce que
prévenu sans doute de l'un rafle
possible
mais imaginant que ça n'était que les
hommes qui seraient concernés il est
allé se cacher avec un de ses beaux
frères
dans le 18e arrondissement également
donc on est venu nous chercher mon père
n'était pas là ce dont j'ai gardé le
souvenir c'est d'avoir un peu marcher
pour aller jusque là rue de la chapelle
où des autobus nous attendait de la ratp
et là le souvenir précis que j'ai
conservée c'est
ma mère qui pleurait alors que moi
j'étais toute contente de faire ce
voyage en autobus que je n'avais pas
l'habitude de faire bien sûr et là vous
arrivez au vel d'hiv et quand vous
racontez votre souvenir du vélo vous
avez ce mot vous dites que c'est un
endroit monstrueux c'est monstrueux
c'est énorme
cécile est une espèce de brouillard qui
reste dans ma mémoire
mais
s'en souvenir précis de de telles
personnes de tel autre
c'est très vague vous êtes avec votre
maman et votre soeur et d'autres
personnes que vous connaissez du
quartier là va se passer un événement
qui va vous sauver la vie en réalité
vous avez la varicelle j'ai la varicelle
alors que ma mère
me conduit au stand de la croix rouge je
l'imaginent et là on diagnostique la
varicelle et donkey mon départ est prévu
pour l'hôpital rothschild
et c'est là où je
j'ai un souvenir précis
c'est ce bijou que vous avez devant vous
et que ma mère a dû mettre à mon cou ce
jour là
le document que l'on voit aden vous
pouvez peut-être expliquer ce que c'est
alors voilà le
l'association des israélites de france
avait atteint une permanence au niveau 2
au niveau du vel d'hiv et ma mère bien
sûr un prix contacté a donné des
indications pour prévenir de ma présence
de mon transfert à l'hôpital pour
prévenir sa soeur
massemin ma mère avait une soeur qui
elle était venue en france beaucoup plus
tôt qui avait pu obtenir sa
naturalisation qui n'a donc pas été
arrêté et à elle l a confié le soin de
suivre ce que je veux ce que je devenais
là votre tante vient chercher la petite
fille que vous êtes à l'hôpital
rothschild avec la varicelle donc
effectivement votre tante qui a été qui
n'a pas été arrêtée et elle y vient avec
mon père avec votre père qui a qui sera
arrêté quelques mois - d'art
contrairement à ce qu'on lui avait
est-ce qu'on lui avait dit et vous êtes
emmené donc dans les deux sèvres chez
une famille on va voir une photo qui a
été prise bien sûr des années plus tard
chez les dupondt une famille des deux
sèvres que vos parents avaient rencontré
lors de la mort de l'ex lors de l'exode
en 1940 là on vous voit petite fille
avec vivi votre frère de guerre vous
dites voilà vous vous cachez où tout cas
vous accueillir jusqu'à la fin de la
guerre voyage pendant deux ans je suis
resté dans les deux sèvres où j'ai vécu
la vie du heureuse d'un enfant
gâté entouré choyé et mais
à la fin de la guerre vous rentrer à
paris avec vous retrouvez votre tante
celle qui vous a alors c'est cette idée
qui m'a suivi qui l avait été se replier
un rodez et dès 1944 elle vient dans les
deux sèvres et elle vient me rechercher
à votre retour à paris vous essayé sans
succès de retrouver votre famille vos
deux parents donc votre soeur votre
oncle et votantes certains de vos
cousins qui ont été déportés de votre
maman il ne vous reste pas grand chose
vous le disiez tout à l'heure ce bijou
qu'elle vous a donné sans doute en
partant du el dib une photo qu'on a vu
et puis une lettre si vous voulez bien
nous en lire quelques mots et peut-être
nous dire ou es ce que vous pensez
qu'elle a été écrite je pense que cette
lettre a été écrite dans le camp de
beaune la rolande et là
ma mère écrit à sa soeur donc à ma tante
et à son mari et elle dit on nous a
emprisonné comme des chiens est installé
comme des cochons la souffrance des
enfants est impossible à décrire il y a
des enfants âgés de 2 ans qui sont
arrêtés comme les adultes et elle écrit
en lady j envoie le texte original
derrière nous et on voit ce mot sur de
papier griffonné parce qu'il a fallu le
faire passer par quelqu'un qui a accepté
de le renvoyer aux deux parents est
votre soeur sont morts à auschwitz vous
n'avez jamais ou quasiment jamais
raconter votre histoire publiquement
comme vous le faites aujourd'hui
pourquoi j'ai mis longtemps parce que
il me semblait que j'étais j'avais une
certaine culpabilité
et puisque moi j'étais la seule à
survivre à tout ce drame et je ne me
voyais pas en train de raconter une
histoire
qui finalement était celle de ma famille
mais et moi j'avais été tellement
épargné que j'avais honte de mettre ma
situation en avant et aujourd'hui les
choses ont changé aujourd'hui les choses
ont changé j'ai eu l'occasion une fois
de parler de cette histoire dans l'est
dans la classe où étaient où se
trouvaient mes petites filles et j'ai
senti qu l'intérêt que sa poule quand
même porté auprès des enfants donc
aujourd'hui je depuis déjà eu ces deux
trois dernières années je ne me répond
un peu plus sur cette situation sur le
drame de ma famille et puis il ya eu un
événement important en 2017 il y a cinq
ans vous avez demandé à ce que les
dupont la famille qui vous a recueilli
dans les deux sèvres qui était à
l'époque déjà décédé soit reconnu juste
parmi les nations par le mémorial de yad
vashem pourquoi c'était important de le
faire et pourquoi est ce qu'il vous a
fallu 70 ans pour le feu eh bien il m'a
fallu soixante dix hommes parce que en
fait
moi j'avais l'impression cette
reconnaissance que je leur devais je la
leur manifestaient régulièrement puisque
le dès le moment où je les ai quittés je
n'ai cessé de les revoir ils ont connu
mon mari dès que je me suis marié je
suis venu représenter mon enfant dès
qu'il est né et en plus mon fils il ya
passé des vacances heureuses donc j'ai
gj continuellement fait des allers
venues avec entre paris les deux serres
et puis quand même un jour la conscience
m'est venue que je voyais autant de
médailles attribuées aux uns et aux
autres que j'ai pensé qu' il devait la
méritait largement j'ai eu la chance de
jeu je me suis attaqué à la préparation
du dossier
j'ai eu la chance qu'il soit admis en
une année on m'a dit que c'était assez
rare et au bout d'une année la médaille
des justes leur a été accordé ce qui a
donné lieu à une cérémonie
dans le commune où ils sont d enterrer
est une commune autre cérémonie dans la
commune où j'ai vécu et donc sur la
photo à l'est du pont ce sont ces ce
couple ce monsieur est cette dame en bas
qui a regroupé sans doute à l'occasion
d'un anniversaire toute leur famille et
vous êtes juste au dessus de monsieur
dupont en blanc madame chasse clovis
vous avez vous l'avez dit un fille un
fils pardon deux petites filles cette
histoire là c'est la leur aussi bien sûr
que vous leur avez transmis que voudriez
vous que les générations d'aujourd'hui
celle de votre famille et les autres
fassent de ce témoignage de cette
histoire là que vous portez ce que je
voudrais c'est que on est d'abord bien
conscience
que l'antisémitisme
là les
tout ce qui peut séparer les êtres
humains est à bannir au maximum ont le
nez on n'a plus le droit aujourd'hui de
séparer les gens selon leur couleur leur
race leur religion ce n'est plus
possible et par ailleurs il
faut quand même dans la vie savoir
qu' on on doit faire preuve à l'égard
des autres de la plus grande
bienveillance de la plus grande humanité
et on se sauve soi-même en sauvant les
autres
on va s'arrêter sur ces très beaux mots
merci infiniment à lisette chasse clovis
est revenu aujourd'hui sur le plateau de
france 24 un entretien à retrouver sur
notre site internet l'information
continue je
[Musique]